what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm your host
Warren Thompson and today we're going to
be talking about the future teams of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe before it was
just the Avengers and the Guardians of
the Galaxy who of course would go on to
fight with the Avengers but now is a
very different time in fact in phase
four we haven't even had an Avengers
team and we still currently don't have
an Avengers team and we're in Phase five
now however we have heard the new
Avengers team is going to start to be
assembled in the MCU very soon however
they are going to be one of many teams
that are going to be established in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe the MCU is
about to expand in a very big way and
with that comes the formation of new
teams and Alex P over at the cosmic
circus did a great article on this be
sure to check it out we're gonna break
down what he said and talk about these
future teams and who is going to be on
these future teams it's definitely about
to be a very exciting time for the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and if you
want to stay up to to date on it be sure
to subscribe so you don't miss out on
any of the latest videos also if you
subscribe and leave a comment to your
automatically entered in our giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox series X A
PS5 some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items the winner gets to pick one item
and we pick a winner at the end of each
month now first and foremost of course
we have to talk about the Avengers the
ogs and a lot of people have been
wondering what is the new Avengers team
going to look like what is the roster
who is going to be on it well of course
it's going to be a combination of new
and old characters and according to Alex
B at the cosmic circus Sam Wilson AKA
our new Captain America will indeed be
the leader of the new team now we've
heard that during Captain America 4
Brave New World The New Avengers team is
kind of going to be established keep in
mind right now there really isn't an
Avengers team and Disney did kind of
confirm that after Avengers end game
they said there is no Avengers team
right now so what we can expect is
simply the establishment of the actual
team existing in the MCU from there
we're going to see the characters come
together and it's going to start with
Sam Wilson's Captain America Alex P
States moving forward Wilson will step
into the Forefront as the new face of
the MCU in a similar position to his
predecessor who of course was Steve
Rogers Captain America he'll have a
heavy task at hand to lead a fresh
diverse and dynamic lineup of Heroes
while continuing the legacy of the
Avengers in an ever-changing world but
of course the question is like we talked
about what is the new roster going to
look like like I mentioned we can expect
to see some old faces but of course some
new faces as well the article States
we'll see Wong Bruce Banner and Captain
Marvel but to expect relatively new
faces as well including shangchi
She-Hulk Joaquin Taurus's Falcon among
other potential candidates now this
makes you wonder about some of the OG
Avengers who are still out there like
Thor and Hawkeye and also what about
Rhodey if you've seen secret invasion
you know we have some questions I'm sure
we'll see these OG Avengers rejoin the
team when it comes to Secret Wars maybe
they don't join for the King Dynasty but
definitely they'll be back for Secret
Wars now for those of you wondering
about our younger Heroes that have been
introduced into the MCU as of recent and
who are about to be introduced to the
MCU as well don't worry they have their
own team the Young Avengers and we have
been talking about the Young Avengers
for a pretty long time now now it might
be a while before we have an actual
Young Avengers titled project but
members who are going to be on the team
in the future are popping up left and
right throughout the MCU according to
Alex B this is a matter of when not if
the Young Avengers are coming in their
own titled project and here's a roster
to expect hate Bishop Cassie Lang Kamal
Khan aka Miss Marvel and Eli Bradley
then of course the maximoff twins Billy
and Tommy yes they are gone for now but
they should be coming back one in Agatha
coven of chaos and the other not too
long after that I'd also like to add
that Scar the son of the Hulk has been
introduced in She-Hulk so he could
possibly play a role in The Young
Avengers team or he could simply have a
pretty big role to play in the world war
Hulk project that we know Marvel Studios
is developing and of course there will
be some other members who have not made
their MCU debut yet who of course we
can't wait to see but then we have the
Thunderbolts who I think and I hope are
about to be a pretty huge success in the
MCU the Thunderbolts are often described
as the mcu's version of The Suicide
Squad The Cosmic circus says that in the
absence of the Avengers and a constantly
growing number of superhuman threats
some people have decided to stop sitting
idly by hoping for a miracle and will
take matters into their own hands one
such individual is Cia director
Valentina Allegra de Fontaine and we
knew that she is the one who put
together the Thunderbolts it might be at
the direction of Thunderbolt Ross or she
could have taken it into her own hands
like the article States and simply told
Ross about it and named the team the
Thunderbolts right now we're kind of
unsure if they're going to name the
Thunderbolt scene after Thunderbolt Ross
like they done in the comics or if
that's simply the name for some other
reason but we pretty much know this team
it's a team made up mainly of reformed
villains and anti-heroes including
Yelena Bulova the Red Guardian the
Winter Soldier U.S agent ghost and
Taskmaster but the cosmic circus States
they advise keeping tabs on director de
Fontaine as she seems interested in
seeking out enhanced individuals who
knows she could find one or two who
might just join the team now we've heard
that the celestial that is sticking out
of the water on Earth tayamat is
possibly made of adamantium adamantium
for those who don't know is what
Wolverine's medal is and we've heard
that the Thunderbolts are going to visit
tayamat which is going to be at this
time an Island an island in which some
enhanced individuals possibly are so
when the Thunderbolts movie arises we
definitely have to keep a lookout for
some mutants then we have the new
Guardians of the Galaxy team and we
already know that Rocket Raccoon is the
new leader Groot is still by his side
craglin is by his side as well we have
some new cosmic Heroes which are Adam
Warlock and phyla Bell and as far as we
know they are going to continue to do
what the Guardians of the Galaxy do they
are still going to own nowhere that's
still going to be their base and the
team will still go throughout the Galaxy
helping other planets and people who
need help and adding phyllable and Adam
Warlock and King Groot to the team
should definitely make for a very
exciting new Guardians team then we have
the eternals the second eternals film
which some people might have forgotten
about but make no mistake the eternals
are a very important group in the MCU
especially since they involve the
celestials and let's not forget erishim
is going to judge the eternals and
determine if the world is worth saving
or destroying so the eternals are very
important as the celestials pose a
direct threat to the entire human
population on Earth now we've had some
conflicting reports about The Eternal
second film since the first film was
released and right now the cosmic circus
stay it's that it's unclear right now
whether or not eternals 2 will fall in
the Multiverse Saga or after it but make
no mistake judgment is coming for the
eternals and for Earth plus the Harry
Style fans gotta get their Star Fox in
the MCU then we have a team that I
myself am personally really looking
forward to I know a lot of people are as
well and that is the midnight Suns
speaking of the eternals the
post-credits scene for the eternals did
set up the midnight Suns we saw kit
Harrington's Black Knight looking at the
Ebony Blade and then we heard the voice
of mahershala Ali's blade and now we
know that the supernatural side of the
MCU is on its way in fact it's already
begun we had werewolf by night and
Doctor Strange and the Multiverse of
Madness and one of my personal favorites
Moon Knight and blade is on its way as
well with an entirely new written script
which is supposed to be better than the
last fingers crossed at least ironheart
is also supposed to be a part of the
supernatural side of the MCU supposedly
introducing Mephisto I know we'll
believe it when we see it but since the
supernatural side is coming it makes
sense that he would be involved
especially given his connection to
doctor strange and Dr Doom who we only
can assume is going to make his way to
the MCU at some point in time plus not
to mention the Merc with the mouth is
about to join the MCU as well so that
could be our midnight Suns team which
sounds really freaking great now of
course we can't forget about one of the
teams that we are most excited to see in
the MCU A Fantastic Four we've done a
lot of videos about the Fantastic Four
on the channel the official cast for The
Fantastic Four has not been decided yet
but so far the Front Runners are Adam
Driver as Mr Fantastic According to some
insiders of Vanessa Kirby has been
offered the role of Sue storm but we're
not sure if she accepted it yet and last
we heard about the Human Torch Joseph
Quinn was being eyed by Marvel Studios
to play the role of the Human Torch many
people know Joseph Quinn from stranger
things and from what we've heard so far
David Diggs is still the top Runner to
play the thing for the Fantastic Four
rumors have stated that Galactus is most
likely going to be the main villain of
the Fantastic Four movie and is going to
be really exciting to see The Avengers
interact with the Fantastic Four
specifically seeing Doctor Strange
interact with Reed Richards since he met
him in the other Universe in Multiverse
of Madness but I think more than
anything right there with the Fantastic
Four fans are really excited to see the
X-Men and the MCU we've talked about the
X-Men a lot on the channel and basically
what you need to know is we are not
going to get the new X-Men team until
after the Multiverse Saga however in the
Multiverse Saga we are going to see some
of the old original X-Men characters
return perfect example is Wolverine Hugh
Jackman is going to return as Wolverine
in Deadpool 3. in Deadpool 3 we are also
going to see some other original X-Men
characters like Cyclops Jean Gray storm
and a few more return as well but it
doesn't end there apparently they're
also going to be showing up in Avengers
Secret Wars now will we see some of the
newer X-Men characters before the
Multiverse Saga ends in a way yes and
the perfect example is Miss Marvel and
no more both are considered mutants in
the MCU however of course they are not
part of an X-Men team the specific new
X-Men team is what we will not see until
after the Multiverse Saga and a good
majority of the new X-Men characters and
mutants coming to the MCU we will see
them after the Multiverse Saga as well
phase 7 is pretty much been titled the
mutant Saga not officially by Marvel but
for most of the fans who know what's
coming so basically in Phase 5 and Phase
6 and Deadpool 3 and in secret Wars we
get to say goodbye to the original X-Men
that we've known and loved all
throughout these years and then we will
get to say hello to our new X-Men team
so the future of the MCU is very bright
and very exciting we have a lot of
really cool new teams coming to the MCU
let us know which one of these you are
most excited for in the comments down
below and please don't forget to give
the video a like And subscribe so you
can stay up to date on all the latest
MCU news you can also find us on patreon
you can check out our website and our
Discord server and of course you can
always follow us on Instagram and
Twitter as always thank you all so much
for watching woof woof